il più delle volte che sui quotidiani
sentiamo parlare di montagna è per
descrivere una tragedia ma io vi
assicuro che l'alpinismo è ben altro
questo è il sun rotore siamo in
patagonia in sudamerica proprio il
confine tra il cile l'argentina è una
montagna che di solito a sferzata dai
venti e insieme alla neve forma quegli
enormi funghi di viaggio che avete visto
sul sul video mi ci sono voluti 35
chilometri di avvicinamento a piedi e
un'intera giornata per arrivare in cima
ma finalmente lo scorso 28 gennaio con
altri due ragazzi tedeschi
sono riusciti a calpestare la cima e per
me è stata la realizzazione di un sogno
come vedete la foto sono un alpinista ma
fino a due anni fa non facevo la stessa
vita avevo sempre un caschetto arancione
in testa e lavoravo come ingegnere
nell'industria della langa se mi
capitava spesso di viaggiare per seguire
le fasi operative dei progetti qui ad
esempio ero in kazakistan
andavo a bordo di queste enormi navi da
costruzione e ci stiamo anche due mesi e
facevo il possibile per allenarmi questo
è il mio trame da portatile dalla verità
valigia che mi seguiva in ogni trasferta
lo attaccava sugli stipiti delle porte
del del bagno dell'albergo oppure su una
trave della nave e attaccandomi su
queste prese li allenavo come potevo
però capite bene che è un'altra cosa
rispetto alla montagna
progettavamo questori vamo queste enormi
robot sottomarini che servono per
l'installazione delle condotte sul
fondale del mare è un lavoro che mi
piace un sacco che però non si sposa
bene con quello che è il mio concetto di
famiglia e per la passione per la
montagna perché dovevo stare troppo
tempo distante da entrambi
e così i due anni fa ho deciso di fare
il grande passo di rimettermi in gioco e
di dare le dimissioni
per iniziare con questi ragazzi il corso
per diventare guida alpina e dedicarmi a
tempo pieno alla mia passione ho
cambiato per inseguire il sogno e per
migliorare il mio stile di vita
sinceramente non è stata una scelta
facile però a due anni di distanza non
tornerei mai indietro
a 14 anni ho iniziato a scalare con mio
padre in dolomiti e la prima cosa che ho
imparato è che in montagna si condivide
ogni esperienza sia i momenti di gioia
che quelli di difficoltà perché alla fin
fine ci leghiamo ad una corda e tutto si
basa su una profonda stima reciproca
qualche anno dopo è iniziato a sognare
pensando a questa parete è la nord ovest
del civetta in dolomiti e questa proprio
questa foto con quella linea rossa che
indica la via che volevo salire
me la sono attaccata sul muro sopra il
comodino in modo tale che ogni mattina
avevo il mio obiettivo è lì davanti e
facevo tutto il possibile per cercare di
realizzarlo e quando è stato il momento
di partire ero pronto sia nella testa
che nel fisico peccato però
mancasse la macchina e così abbiamo
stipato tutto sulla vespa la mitica px
150 e siamo partiti carichi come muli in
direzione delle montagne
da lì è iniziata la vera avventura
quando il mattino dopo abbiamo messo
mani e piedi sulla roccia fino a sera
quando a fatica e stanchi morti
siamo entrati nella marca con più di 700
metri di vuoto sotto di noi qui non si
vede il mattino dopo
abbiamo raggiunto la cima ed è stata una
soddisfazione immensa
in quel momento però non riuscivo bene a
rendermene conto perché ero ancora
concentrato su tutte le fatiche che ci
mancavano per scendere
in alpinismo come nella vita non tutte
le ciambelle riescono con il buco e la
ritirata fa sempre parte del gioco saper
valutare i propri limiti e quando serve
tornare indietro è sicuramente una delle
capacità più grandi che a richiesta di
un alpinista
in questi ultimi anni poi ho iniziato
anche a viaggiare per scoprire nuove
montagne e culture diverse e del primo
viaggio che ho fatto in india ricordo in
particolare questo momento
viaggiavano in treno girovagando con lo
zaino in spalla e un giorno siamo
capitati in questa carrozza
completamente invasa da un famiglia
indiana che era in festa per il
matrimonio è stato un'esperienza
incredibile di cibi di musica di sorrisi
che difficilmente dimenticherò
dell'ultimo viaggio invece in patagonia
il sudamerica è stata entusiasmante
acquistare questa auto usata a
costruirci un letto di legno dentro e
allestirla con tutto l'occorrente per
vivere tre mesi itineranti in sudamerica
potevamo fermarci dove volevamo seguendo
completamente i nostri ritmi e per
chiudere il cerchio
lo scorso novembre
ho finito il corso per diventare
aspirante guida alpina
adesso per me si apre un nuovo mondo
dove devo far vivere ai miei clienti le
stesse emozioni che ho provato per anni
in montagna
questa è la mia idea di montagna che per
me è uno stile di vita e la mia valvola
di sfogo è un modo incredibile per
divertirsi per plasmare il proprio
carattere
il bello di questo sport è che non ha
età e soprattutto alla portata di tutti
che si faccia un semplice trekking una
ferrata o una salita più impegnativa le
tra le emozioni che vengono trasmesse
sono sempre le stesse
quindi abbiate il coraggio di cambiare
di seguire i vostri sogni e di provare
qualcosa di nuovo anche andando in
montagna grazie